welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we break down all the
latest movies new game releases TV shows
and comic books Queen and slim is a film
that definitely feels like the sleeper
here of the air and it's something
that's stuck with me since seeing it due
to its symbolism overall story and
ending I've kind of wrestled with doing
this video as I don't want to be another
white guy rambling on about a struggle
that I don't really know anything about
so I've taken a lot of time researching
the director and write his thoughts on
the film in order to analyze the movie
with a better understanding of certain
choices that were made throughout this
video we're going to be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the movie and what we took the overall
journey to mean there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to see the film yet and don't
want to know what happens then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into our breakdown of Queen and slim
okay so Queen and slim starts off simple
enough and it follows two characters
that find themselves thrust into a
nationwide manhunt after a police stop
escalates into a shooting the movie
opens with Queen played by Jody Turner
Smith on a date with slim played by
Daniel Cole ouya and he becomes clear
early on that the two don't really have
a connection with one another this motif
kind of exemplifies the movie and it's
really about people from all walks of
life coming together for one unified
goal Queen is a defense attorney that
has just learned that one of her clients
has been sentenced to death whereas slim
is a religious teetotal man that likes
to keep his head down but the characters
names were deliberately chosen by the
director Melina Matsoukas because she
stated that all women in the black
community or Queens and slim is
something that black people are often
called in a derogatory manner they are
worlds apart and those slim is hopeful
for more from Queen it's clear that
she's not that interested when driving
her home a queen takes Slim's phone and
when grabbing it back he swims in the
road which grabs the attention of a
patrolling police officer who pulls them
over and begins to search the car the
situation escalates and it's a scenario
that we've seen play out numerous times
on the news in which an officer killed
an unarmed black person under the
pretense that they were
threat I'm sure many people watching the
movie have gone through similar
circumstances themselves in which the
police have pulled them over for a minor
incident and even though they were
cooperating they've ended up with a gun
pointed at them for doing little more
than asking some questions Queen and
slim follows the usual narrative of this
but where it differs is that when Queen
tries to film the incident she is shot
at and in self-defense slim manages to
wrestle a policeman getting his gun and
using it on the officer killing him in
the process it's a really tense scene
and it definitely grabbed my attention
early on I actually saw Queen and slim
at something that's known as the secret
screening which you have no idea what
movie you're going to see and having
absolutely no prior knowledge of the
work this introduction really gripped me
the two really only have two choices
hand themselves in or go on the run it
wouldn't be much of a movie doing the
former so instead they choose the latter
which leads them to inadvertently cause
a political movement in the country
whilst they try and evade the long arm
of the law the two are really seen as
heroes so the black lives matter cause
and because of this it begins to make
the black community realise that enough
is enough they're sick of being harassed
and this needs to stop now the film
begins in Ohio and this was deliberately
chosen by the creative team as it's one
of the last stops on the Underground
Railroad when discussing the movie with
Oprah Magazine the writer of the film
Lena weaith stated that I've always seen
this as a kind of reverse slave escape
narrative they're kind of on a journey
on the Underground Railroad the
modern-day Underground Railroad Queen
states in the film that Ohio still
imposes the death penalty and the 2014
shooting of Tamir rice also happened
close to the area the car that slim
drives a white Accord was also picked
intentionally because on the street in
which the murder occurred six cars were
pulled over in the space of an hour
including one which was the same make
and model that slim drives the bar that
the duo eventually make it to for their
second date is also called the
underground and once more the movie
hints that this is about
african-americans escaping oppression it
definitely has this aspect to it and the
film is basically a road trip that
involves encountering people from all
walks of life but at its core is the
notion that family and community are of
the utmost importance I have seen some
complain
at this film tars white policeman with
the same brush but firstly these types
of stops turned bad all too often and
secondly we do see firsthand that our
sheriffing Kentucky is willing to help
the to only turning on them after he
hears about the officer that they shot a
white couple are also paramount in
helping Queen and slim escape and they
offer the two refuge at their home
during the investigation in this scene
Queen and slim have to hide under
floorboards which were used in the
Underground Railroad to smuggle people
to Canada and it reminds us that history
though long gone still plays a big part
in our present and it's called though is
the black community and how they must
come together in order to fight the
oppression and they face and that unity
is the only way to accomplish this the
film basically states that people must
put their differences aside in order to
aid one another and to me this is
exemplified in queens estranged Uncle
Earl who we learned killed her mother
it's revealed that Queen helped him
avoid jail for the crime by becoming his
defense attorney and to me this hammers
home the point that this is about an
overall message of kinship for an
achieved enlightenment we must forget
those that have wronged us and help
where possible and even those from all
walks of life share some commonality
they changed their appearance and hatch
a plan to escape to Cuba and along the
way they visit the underground for their
second date and also meet a young boy
who is the son of a mechanic that is
fixing their car the character named
junior says that they've really created
a movement in the country and that he's
going to go to a protest the next day
tragically this ends with junior
shooting a black police officer and in
turn being shot himself
the director stated that this highlights
the dangers that expressing your beliefs
can lead to you and shows that even in
the black community there are voices
that may try and get you to step into
self-censorship in order to keep their
standing this sort of plays into the
ending of the film but the movie doesn't
say that all black members of the police
force are bad and that there are
opportunities for those within the
sanctions of the authorities to help
their community out this is showcasing
the police officer that lets them escape
in the film and eagle-eyed viewers may
have spotted that his name is Langston
this is a nod to Langston Hughes a poet
that was a huge part of the Harlem
Renaissance eventually they reach a man
who says he can lead them to a man
plane in which they will be able to
escape to Cuba by this point the bounty
on the two combined is at half a million
dollars and they are very sought-after
the man drives the two to the tarmac and
finally to the plane that will take them
away however police officers arrive and
draw their weapons on the pair an
overzealous police woman shoots Queen
killing her instantly and slim crouches
over her devastated at the death and the
police shouted him to get on the ground
however he defiantly stands up refusing
to be silenced any further and picks up
Queen to me this symbolizes that though
the black community has faced losses and
deaths they must rise up and continue
marching forward Slim is killed as well
and the police say that this was
necessary as the two were considered
armed and dangerous as we could see
Slim's hands were carrying Queen and he
wasn't really posing a danger beyond
being defiant as with most cases the
police didn't have any reason to shoot
him but they did anyway out of fear and
prejudice it's a devastating moment and
initially though I was shocked by this
move I realized it was the only way that
the film could have gone Queen and slim
were never going to escape to a life of
freedom as they are stuck in a society
that will constantly put them down
without reason because it's designed to
hold them back when discussing the white
female officer who shot Queen without
provocation
the creative team said it serves as a
sort of commentary on the phenomenon of
white feminism which often finds black
women's Caucasian counterparts choosing
to ignore the intersectionality of
equality for all in reaction to the 2018
murder of 18 year-old near Wilson
Harper's Bazaar to find it as type of
behavior that rests under the guise of
feminism only as long as it's
comfortable only as long as it's
personally rewarding only as long as it
keeps on brand to put it simply a woman
shooting a fellow female served as an
example of the betrayal of sisterhood
and unity that put so many people in our
culture in harm's way Queen and slim
have a funeral which hundreds attend and
the two are made into martyrs unifying
people around their cause however we
also learn that the person that sold
them out was the one that drove them to
the tarmac and this holds a lot of
weight about her separation and greed
will often cause communities to collapse
when discussing this
twist the director said we wanted it to
be complicated we wanted it to show how
we're socialized what the effects of
racism do to our community like the
black man who sells them out he's a
victim of capitalism in that moment
you're not thinking of values you're
just thinking how am I gonna eat and
that's what this man is thinking of in
that moment he's thinking of himself as
an individual and has sold out the
community in order for his own
individual growth and that's all of us
we all have to deal with that in our
community how do we do that
how do we support each other how do we
unify it's a really poignant moment that
reminds us that short-term and material
goals overall take away from the broader
scope of things and progression in the
long term I might be being a snob but
just looking at the character you can
see that it was solely focused on the
short term as he lived in a trailer yet
still put his money towards girls and
souping up his car it's this image of
success that he has fallen victim to and
rather than seeing his community being
successful and make a stand he is
focused solely on the success of himself
he has clearly helped people in the past
due to his reputation for doing so but I
guess half a million dollars was just
too much to turn down the film shows how
close people have often come to getting
away
and moving on to a new way of life with
a more positive meaning but how one
selfish person can bring it all down and
in the end we must recognize the
failings of the character who sold them
out and make sure that we do not repeat
these actions ourselves it's an awesome
way to close the movie and Queen and
slim is one of the most engaging films
that I've watched in a long time this is
stuck with me long after seeing it and
it's an incredible way to close out the
air massively recommend that if you
haven't seen it already then you go and
check it out as this is a film that
drives discussion and deserves to get
more attention in the end Queen and slim
is brilliant and it gets a nine out of
ten now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the film and what you took
from the ending as I said up top I'm a
white guy trying to analyze a movie
about racial politics so I apologize if
I was disrespectful or misinformed on
some things I just have to take the film
as I saw it and what those behind the
movie intended if you enjoyed the video
then please give it a thumbs up and
something a little more lighthearted
make sure you check out my breakdown of
the black widow trailer which would be
linked at the end we go over everything
you missed and give our theories on the
film's so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more if you want
to come chat to me after the video that
make sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey will head over to my
discord server which you'll be linked in
the description below you drop videos on
there early so if you want to see stuff
before anyone else and that's the best
place to be it's free to join and we
have an awesome community so hopefully I
see you over there very soon we're also
giving away a free copy of the marble
phase 3 part 2 boxer on blu-ray which
contains Black Panther infinity war and
Game Captain Marvel amour and all you
have to do to be in with the chance of
winning it's like the video make she's
subscribe to the channel and leave you
thoughts on Queen and slim in the
comment section below the winners gonna
be chosen at random on the 15th of
December and the set will be shipped out
from then whoever gets the prize it's
the best of luck that everyone who takes
part this is a channel for people who
are mad into movies so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time
take care peace
you